our good friend Adonis Paul has been
covering somebody okay
he's been covering this guy called armed
liberal there's only 274 Subs though I'm
liberal now virgin can you give me some
background on arm liberal please
uh well he's a patriot okay first and
foremost he's a patriot okay that's good
to know he knows more about the Second
Amendment than you do you [__] you
[__] maggot okay oh so like yeah
well we'll see about that you [__]
spell the normal way yeah just so you
don't have to there's nothing spell the
normal I wasn't being cute no it's no
subtlety there he worships uh a liberal
Satan okay liberal State not like
regular Satan but I assume liberal Satan
is like Hillary Clinton it's a woman I
was going to say it's a woman as opposed
to conservative difference well
conservative Satan is uh I'd say
probably Alan dershowitz
I don't know it seems more like
conservative Satan's lawyer
um
so he's so armed liberal is a rapper
yeah and he raps that's the most
important part of course so is he is he
good
uh I mean well his name is Devastator
with a Y and you know this song is this
song is Devastator is Velvet villain AKA
armed liberal AKA Bobby bottle service
bottle service he's literally doing the
same height they call me devastated they
call me argon they call me nightmaster
they call me pink dress they call me
armed liberal get ready
that's the one I was trying to think of
I'm like it was something Arbuckle
[Laughter]
I'm gonna drop I'm gonna drop the link
to AP stream on this side yes yes drop
it drop it Adonis Paul thank you for
this
check out Adonis Paul on Rumble
Matt riddle
no isn't he in rehab
[Music]
is this for real this isn't a gag right
no this is not this [__] is dead
serious do you want me to pull some more
videos yeah yeah no it's fine I just
want to make sure okay
wait this is how he sounds yeah like on
purpose like on purpose
oh that hurts oh this is crane child
this is pretty bad this is pretty up
this up there [__] liberal Tom
McDonald
[Music]
it's like I don't get it too because
it's like he looks like an 80s metal guy
but he's trying to rap and he's got
flaming swords but he's like you're
trying to rap but you no this isn't
Lauren Southern now shut up guys no this
is uh Sebastian yuck
please
this is MySpace the person but like now
yes
yeah it does look like a guy it does
look like a guy like woke up after a
coma and it's like the last thing he
remembers was 2008. let's go back to
rear differential Rose over here
[Music]
oh wow he's bad
dear white people
let's let's not let's let's not if you
if you grew up around predominantly
white people but let me do something
about rap if you're going to talk to
white people let me just make sure black
people can't listen and put some stuff
on so they can't hear when this is
playing here you go go ahead thank you
uh it's just us whites it's now it's
listening
stop rapping okay unless you grew up
around that sort of culture
you're not gonna be good at it the only
white people who are good at rapping
we're around other talented black people
and they're just mimicking what they
learned when they were younger yeah it's
actually a really good point you can't
just learn it in your 30s
enough this has been a [__] Public
Service Announcement okay I'm gonna let
everyone come back in okay there you go
Trenton Wade's probably saying I only
hear us humming I can't hear anything
there was a humming for a while that was
just playing from the show
can't you see you can't spell Fame
without me talking video game when I
speak of Destiny 1986 that began my
excellent Journey my mother
my accent let your knee so you're 36
years old and you're doing this the
batch life goes the music is bad and you
should feel bad thank you five bucks you
just revealed your your birthday so
you're you're 36 years old yeah he's a
grown ass man and you're doing this yeah
okay you're not
the dream's not happening kid I don't
know what to tell you if it ain't if it
ain't [__] cracking by now my man it
ain't gonna happen yeah you're too
enough you're too close to having to get
your prostate checked to be [__]
trying to start a rap career
you're right
you're on the wrong side of 30 buddy
yeah I'm sorry but if you're still on
band camp and you're still you're
writing rhymes about colonoscopies then
you might be [__] past the dream
buddy yeah seriously it's not working
anymore
if you're going this is my year and it's
the fifth year in a row you're going
this is my year you know what it was the
reason to become a mega star covert
really [__] them up man oh that's what
happened a couple years yeah that's why
his career didn't take off in rap when
he was 34. yeah you're right
you're right it was covered that [__]
passed them by not the world they beat
me in this Cipher they beat me in this
Cipher yeah Brothers beat me in the
ciphers trans [__] jerks
surfing don't get it twisted that's not
true this guy's nothing like Dayton
hyper and over this guy's parents are
still alive because somebody's paying
for this stupid video and it ain't him
not on your Uber Eats [__] money
hey you just lift too okay let's do the
[__] door Dash he's doing all of
Postmates oh yeah listen here what
[__] your rap name should be
taskrabbit [__] [__]
now go get me some [__] condoms at
7-Eleven you piece of [__] and some
combos right and some swirly pop bangs
they only happened at 7-Eleven
instead that became the strongest man
this guy every time every time he talked
to him he's like oh actually I I was
kicked out of the original Dirty Heads
or I would have made it yeah
well I mean I wasn't in the band I was
hanging around them when they started
out yeah so I was like part of the band
oh actually uh Rome gave me a tattoo
when he was a tattoo artist that's true
the strongest man in the Galaxy
just a few when he's standing now
they're just even yeah you'll see when
he's standing behind the with the there
we go he's so funny why he's filming
this somebody comes out that door to
empty trash into the dumpster it's like
some guy in a Chinese restaurant comes
out
some guy from some guy comes on a Wawa
shirt and he's just smoking a cigarette
you know film here I told you you know
you know film here
dishwasher with a hair net comes on
smoking a cigarette looking at him
you know my favorite part of that scene
is the word art graffiti that he has up
at the top that's not [__] real hold
on let's take a look at it oh yeah oh my
God
he didn't even try does he sell shirts
because we're all getting one we're all
getting a velvet villain shirt okay
isn't that a Danny Saint is fighting for
the belt next week
in the Galaxy even the stars are
confused by my story not looking for
American empathy instead I'm developing
my own devastating Legacy are you
are you you're 36 in your big hit rap
video has like [__] what is it how
many views 1.4k views and I'm sure the
majority of that's from AP in this
audience they're from the guy with the
top comment that's making fun of you AP
stop comment
this is the most amazing thing I've ever
seen I mean like it
what devastating Legacy like you're
literally the most popular you're ever
going to be now is because you're being
made fun of by a [__] cartoon man
who's not even real that's going to be
the peak of your career that's a good
point like what are you talking about
this is going to be the most eyes you're
ever gonna have in your life on you and
the sad part is is like in a year
everyone's gonna move on it'll be back
to 200 views three months yeah well it
depends on how much you [__] Spurs
that's a good point oh you know if he
starts making karate videos for nurses
Jesus Christ we have a problem is there
anyone better than James Bergs uh I just
I sent you a link rights to his response
to AP well that's his first mistake no
no no no no
okay
before we hit play here oh God before I
even see a word of what you're about to
say Sir I've already identified the
first mistake you've made in this
situation
which is responding at all
the cartoon oh no okay do me a favor
Virgie see if you get Adonis to hop into
the Discord you get him in there all
right
bro he's [__] gonna rip the Bible
you know what he did he went to a Barnes
Noble and he put it in the [__]
fiction section oh [__] bro that's
[__] edgy and it turned on the bars
that opened him and closed for 10 years
because it's a [__] bookstore
Hey sir I'm gonna let you know right now
I know what you're trying to do you're
trying to trigger the Christian Nazi
[__] white guys and all that by
ripping up a Bible
um
I don't really care I mean I if that
were my Bible I might shoot you yeah
just because you're [__] with my
property yeah by the way that was by
anything I would because it's mine if
Royce walked in here tearing up a Bible
my only question would go hey is that my
Bible and he goes no I'll be like oh I
don't give a [__] and then I go [__]
throw whatever they're gonna book a
Mormon and Marsh helps me yeah
oh oh it's me again the um
wait and again I want to emphasize this
guy is 36 yeah years old 36.
yeah so yeah because I was in high
school once too
that's what I mean this is I mean
honestly this is every bucket it's awful
High School personality no it's so it's
really bad it's really bad
and today
I'm here to talk about
pissing off Mega Republicans
oh is that what we are that's what's
about to happen we're about to you hey
you ready about to get triggered you
know snowflake you know there's nothing
I love more
than somebody who's just so sure of
where the trolling's coming from like
it's the old temp pool I know it's not
me I know I'm not the problem so it must
be those Mega Republicans how many times
have been called bag of Republicans
we've been called liberal [__] antifa
it's whatever you've made up in your
head as you're all these are the people
trying to Brigade me automatically it's
those people I can assure you merch just
so people have it though I'm gonna send
you the link in the rumble chat
to this video so people have it I'll
have you know and I can't speak for
Donna's Paul but you know I'm sure Royce
would agree with me and I'm sure AP
probably would agree with me all three
of us would kick Donald Trump into a
[__] kick him right in the chest into
a volcano we don't care to satisfy the
[__] low-cal Gods whatever to keep
the cattle to keep the cattle from like
[__] you know what I mean to keep the
Harvest going we would sacrifice him in
a heartbeat we're not maggot people
relax Bud the bets left goes he
destroyed a Bible and I just asked to
destroy like 10 billion more copies and
the Bible will be good
10 billion conservatively you guys saw
you guys saw his newest video on armed
liberal right was it a new one arm
liberal channel the most recent video
with the most recent one triggered Mega
Nazi known as Adonis yeah we're
literally we're literally we're watching
right now that's the one okay yeah Jesus
Virgie good yeah yeah come on
[__] you Frozen
laughs
hey what did Murphy say five minutes ago
let me repeat it
you see yesterday was the national day
of hate no it wasn't that's another
thing that was so silly every day by the
way the national day of hate you know
what I I heard about it maybe four times
throughout the week do you know where I
heard about it from
Ben Shapiro Jonathan Greenblatt Matt
Walsh it was the same guys I didn't hear
one well first of all there's nobody
that like you know is dissident right or
even white like nationalists whatever
they don't use the word hate they're not
like bro let's get together for our hate
rally bro it was the biggest [__]
glow up and it came and went and you
guys were so disappointed nothing
happened
it was a far look man stop waving that
Airsoft around not everybody's got eye
protection on
so
please enjoy the next
inspiration no it's you shouldn't do
that on YouTube I'm just trying to help
you out but yeah buddy I mean
oh oh
yeah what is this guy flocksterness is
Next to Godliness
it does look tempting
and that will be our show for the
evening ladies and gentlemen so let's
get started with some funsies I got some
funsies watch look at this there's this
guy so let me tell you a story there's
this guy that I trigger on Twitter so
[__] bad right
horrifically using all the local slang
and [__] and then I you know maybe like
I went and took a nap I came back [__]
him a little more and then I saw finally
that YouTube YT was in his app it was
the armed liberal YT
right and this kid was serious as [__]
man he's a dumb [__] he was
taking L after L after L trying to
defend this day of hate thing being like
no it's real and all this [__] I'm like
nothing [__] happens you little [__]
[Applause]
show you this guy's Channel
wow in this context it's even worse even
better when you're just looking at all
of his thumbs yes but the best part is
this is the armed liberals showing you
AP putting his foot directly up his
[__] ass
about and by the way armed liberal I
love the certain liberal guy he's my
favorite guy in the world can I [__]
Lefty [__] I I have to say
I can I congratulate him for a sec I
want to congratulate you honestly
um I'm almost 40 right I don't get a lot
of Firsts in life anymore and pretty
much everything I'm ever going to do
I've done a million times this is a
first for me and I want to congratulate
you for being
the only guy I've ever seen who owns
this many weapons that I am absolutely
not scared I know at all
I'm scared of anyone that owns at least
two guns right bro he's gonna reap
something you own 240 guns and I'm not
I've never been less scared of a guy who
owned more guns oh my God it's just it's
so bad right this guy could pull an
AR-10 out in front of me and I would
start laughing
this is satire this [__] is serious
he thinks this [__] is scary 36 years
old wait
and you're gonna You're Gonna Keep
saying oh AP I think it's satire it's
not I've looked into it
[Music]
oh my God look at those little baby
hands oh look at those little baby songs
you're really you're a warrior
he's such a [__] [__] you're a
warrior hey papa Don is Paul's channel
in there if everyone could subscribe I
know I I know I never forget my manicure
day no hanging yeah hey Rumble how about
uh throwing uh Donna's Paul a little
check mark action yeah he's a good guy
he does good work little boy
there's a lot of things your elders can
tell about you that way if you guys ever
doing it you guys could do a big event
in Toontown and not invite him
look the problem was Mickey Mouse was
here Mickey Mouse was here and we didn't
want him
to see that you know but look if you
ever wanna if you ever want a tour of
Toontown you're welcome to come you're
welcome to come you know just Russell
Brand's still there yeah
just not when Mickey and bugs are here
not when they're here
but I tell you what you know who's gonna
be in here next week Droopy Dog you want
to meet Droopy Dog no okay never did
oh it was kicked off YouTube for my
views on the Jewish people